good citizens of the reject Nation you spoke I
listened after that Monumental villains list it
is time to dive into some Heroes now we cut this
off at 75 a whopping 75 Euros this could have
easily been like 150 200. honorable mention goes
out to The Howling Commandos to Hogan to Hank and
Janet themselves there are so many heroes in the
MCU at this point that I had to limit this to 75
because it could have gone on forever but here
we have 75 of the greatest heroes in the MCU
ranked and right after this break I'll tell you
how we decided to rank him but first do leave a
like comment let me know what else you want to
see I made this one because I saw everyone say
they wanted Heroes list so here we are let me
know what else you want to see and do all the
YouTube things share this with your friends let
them know I will say before we get into this I am
a little under the weather still so if there's
a slight energy lull I do apologize for all of
you that like being 11. I'm still like a nine
but I'm only human all right let's get into it
[Music] all right so to make this list for me
I'm not gonna lie this took about two hours to
decide who is in what order which Heroes I wanted
to include which ones would make the cut it was a
long process but I ended up breaking it down to
four key attributes one was their transformation
from the comic and that's what's gonna make this
list a little more unique this is still based
within the MCU but if a character is between like
50 and 49 that's what's gonna Edge them over just
a little bit is how well I think they made them
improve from the comic book another thing was the
authenticity to their MCU Arc how authentic one
character feels from their movie to a crossover
movie to a team-up movie all those things are
very important so their authenticity of their
Arc within the MCU another thing I had in mind
was how compelling they are how much you want
them on the screen how entertaining they are how
how much you feel for them how much you feel like
them their authenticity to the character and
their overall development was very important
and lastly heroism itself these are heroes so I
took heroic attributes into account so those are
the four main categories how heroic how authentic
how it translates from comic and their overall Arc
in the MCU and how much that felt true let's get
into it coming in at number 75 is Gilgamesh now
Gilgamesh is from the eternals a movie I espouse
often I love this movie very very much but what
makes Gilgamesh Stand Out is in a movie with an
ensemble cache he's especially heroic in the way
he handles not just the macro of the world
the catastrophizing the global stuff but his
relationship with Dina I love how contained that
relationship is I love how human that relationship
is and I love what selflessness looks like for
Gilgamesh and that's what makes a hero and that's
a really unique relationship really love this
character really love how he's used number 75.
coming at number 74 is fendral now he had the
deficit of being recast between his first and
second appearance but both actors including the
leading man performance of Zachary Levi were very
charming and very intricate and very fun there
was a specificity to this playfulness this Robin
Hood ass character that I did think elevated
the Thor films I wish we had a little bit more
of him I wish we got to learn a little bit more
about this character but besides just being part
of the Warriors 3 but I do think that Bond what um
that that brought out in Thor was very very useful
and I wish we could have seen more to really flesh
out Thor but for now he's 74. coming in at number
73 in the highest of the Warriors Three I did
mention Hogan was an honorable mention at the
top of this video he'd be like 78 if we did 100 of
these but we've got number 73 volstag as played by
Ray Stevenson now this man is a Powerhouse he is
our Punisher at times he is also usually a Villain
at other times he's the villain of rrr this man
is everywhere and he brings so much levity to this
role very intense actor playing a comedic role
almost Santa claus-esque I love the beauty of
this comedy I love the physicality of this comedy
I love that every time a volstag is on screen I
want to know more he's also someone who sacrifices
himself and that is about as heroic as it gets
while being a force of levity while also being a
force of power like I would fear this character
this God of hunger and War full stack is awesome
check him out number 73 number 72 now this one
might be a bit lower than a lot of people would
prefer but there's a very specific reason for
this and that is going to be pepper pots as rescue
and that is mainly because her two appearances as
rescue as opposed to being as pepper pots felt
very incomplete it felt like there were scenes
missing it felt like there were edits I loved
when we had moments of heroism from pepper pots
because the pepperpot's Tony Stark relationship is
foundational to my love of a very high up number
on this list Tony Stark I love what Pepper Potts
represents and I love what she does for the Stark
Foundation I love her keeping Tony in line I
love her being able to outsmart Tony on many
many terms and ways but I don't like that as soon
as you put on the suit it kind of went away I did
feel like all of the intelligence and capability
and resourcefulness and all those things that make
pepper so interesting as soon as the iron suits
on it's another Iron Man and that that puts her
pretty low because that's not the character so
rescue's pretty low for me while Pepper Potts is
high gotta land here at number 72. number 71 is a
character I have not understood and that has been
very hard for me in this age of comedy in the
Marvel ERA this is a character so many people
love and I don't get it uh he's funny I laugh I
don't really invest and a lot of people really
had a whole thing to say especially in love and
thunder that is Korg I don't get the Korg thing
um he's perfectly fine and that is why he's 71.
perfectly fine cork coming at number 70 is a
character that I expect to elevate as soon as her
show comes out this is a character I want to see
more of so I get the feelings I want to get this
is a character from David Mack one of my favorite
comic creators of all time and I have not felt
this from the MCU version of the character yet
and that is Echo Echo is a fascinating character
in the comic books Echo is so resourceful and
enigmatic and interesting and makes you lean into
the character and want to learn more about her
backstory and all these things and I felt like
the way she was used as supporting character and
the way she was used in Hawkeye was almost like
a henchman and and that didn't feel right didn't
feel authentic it felt like she's meant to be so
much more and I didn't get that from her yet the
show coming out is gonna flesh this character
out she will not live this low certainly by
this time uh next year two years from now but
for now with the portrayal we got so far much
like in my villains list Kingpin from the Netflix
series is one of my favorite villains of all time
hard stop Kingpin in the MCU Allah Hawkeye is
one of my lower because of the disappointment
between the duality of those characters much like
Echo is going to be lower here Echo is landing at
number seven coming in at number 69 is Icarus now
Icarus is in the eternals and Icarus stands out
as the Superman s character and in an age of
invincible and the boys and all of these dark
Superman archetypes Icarus has a tall order to do
luckily he's played by Richard Madden so he can
carry that that said the twist did feel fairly
telegraphed from earlier on in the film luckily
this movie has a lot of twists this movie has a
lot of turns this movie goes a lot of places but
I did feel like Icarus was definitely a character
I would have loved to see more of for the Twist
and I do feel like it was a little bit expected
because of this age of Dark Superman so I enjoyed
the performance I like the portrayal I understood
most importantly where he was coming from he was
following orders he was super cop he was a cop
just doing what he was told and that did make
him captivating that's why he's not lower but the
twist being so telegraphed keeps him on the lower
side at number 69. number 68 likewise with a Twist
feeling a bit telegraphed and that unfortunately
shortchanging the heroism and short-changing
the character I'm gonna go with Sharon Carter
now Sharon Carter totally works in Winter Soldiers
Sharon Carter totally works throughout Civil War
but by the time we get to where her art goes
as the power broker I'm a lot less invested in
the character and that's not to fault the actor
just like none of these other performances are
are bad it felt like it was to serve the plot
not to serve the character and sometimes when
you're making this giant tapestry of the MCU some
things have to serve the plot if it short changes
the character that's so be it so unfortunately for
now and I'm hoping this changes with Thunderbolts
Sharon Carter number 68 I'm hoping to see agent 13
evolve agent 13 will be rad to see I'd like to see
agent 13 more than the power broker we'll see 68
Sharon Carter number 67 Red Guardian I love David
Harbor I love him a lot he's fun he's interesting
he's a delight to interview he's a good man
I like David Harbor in the MCU I don't however
see where the red guardian's gonna go as being
important enough for the Thunderbolt he was a very
fun supporting character in Black Widow that's
what I thought his purpose was going to stay the
opening of the film is why he's as high as he is
but that's not when he's Red Guardian that's when
he's playing the Spy father of Black Widow and and
Yelena I want to get more of that paternal nature
and more of the conflict I definitely by the end
felt the paternal conflict between betraying his
daughters but I want to see more of that I do
want to see him as more of a hero I do think we're
gonna get that from Thunderbolts he's in a tricky
spot so he doesn't have a lot of screen time
yet so for now Mr David Harbor is Red Guardian
is number 67. all right number 66 is not really
a hero at all but I felt like I had to include
him because I think to some people's eyes he is a
hero and his captivating nature put him this high
on the list remember that was one of my factors
what makes them unique is also part of what makes
them heroic in this this judgment this U.S agent
now U.S agent is a fascist following orders much
like Icarus so they're Heroes of their own mind
no one acts out of villainy but he's definitely
done things wrong but he often times showed that
his heart was in the right place as far as his
belief like as long as he believed that would help
people he was doing it for helping people that
that's a hero but he hasn't done a lot right yet
so it's really tricky I love the conflict I feel
about this character he is just following orders
he's following government orders and that's that
conflict from Winter Soldier you know cap Steve
Rogers doesn't just follow Waters blindly and
that's what causes the conflict that leads to
Civil War from Winter Soldier us agent would
and he would do it from the right place for the
wrong reasons very tricky character very excited
to see more of him in Thunderbolts we've got Mr
John Walker at number 66. all right number 65
is going to be quick because we don't really know
them as a hero yet but they deserve an honorable
mention because I love them dearly they're not
hero yet because they're kind of a punk they cause
a lot of problems they're a bit of a nuisance but
every time they're on screen I'm so happy they're
usually dancing this is Baby Groot slash teenage
Groot about to get into some heroism we've seen
the Guardians the Galaxy 3 trailer we're gonna see
what swole Groot brings remember Groot OG and this
group separate groups Baby Groot has caused more
problems than good so far but he's adorable and
he has done some heroic acts so I gotta put them
a little higher than a lot of these people Baby
Groot I love you number 64 and one of my biggest
surprises of the MCU shows I did not expect this
character this is a very deep cut character in a
deep cut show I've always considered Moon Knight
to be you know a c-less character I never thought
would get the time of day and then Scarlet Scarab
are number 64. Scarlett's carob this actress
every time she was on screen I was so enamored
and fascinated and I wanted to know more about the
relationship and I and I was was more intrigued by
the disassociative identity of all of the Oscar
Isaacs because of her performance and then when
you give her the full superhero treatment she gets
those awesome Wings we get a little bit of action
from her in heroic character we got lots of action
from her just as a civilian badass performance a
lot of great stunt work a lot of practical work
and earned her wings earned the heroism really
enjoyed to this take I want to see more from
Scarlet Scarab but she's number 64. number 63
is higher than would have expected but I couldn't
think of a place to put him on the list any lower
and it's it's because of the limited screen
time I was just so impressed at what he was
able to do so quickly this is a character that
I don't particularly love from the comic books
I don't mind him but I'm never invested like
I read his comics and I and I bought his mini
series but I wasn't like this guy's my guy that's
Black Bolt I was so impressed at what Anson Mount
did with Black Bolt in very little screen time
and no dialogue obviously as Black Polk can't
speak this man emanated reality he emanated
power he emanated an interest you wanted to
know more about him he took out Thanos like in
in the matter of minutes I love that elseworld
scene or that alternate universe scene of him and
the Moon that beautiful Illuminati shot of all of
them taking out Thanos is so powerful and he's the
only member of the Illuminati that makes this list
because what he was able to do with so little was
so impressive and it's the character I want to see
more of if we do an else world what if jump into
any of those other multiverses really liked Hanson
Mount as uh the great Black Bolt number 63. all
right we got a newcomer here coming in at number
62 she just made her debut in wakanda forever and
she is about to get her own Series in Iron Heart
ever Charming Ever captivating Dominique Thorne
as ironheart now she has a lot to balance she is
a Legacy character in that she puts out an Iron
Man suit they even call it out in the movie she
has to be witty and charming and different she's
got to have a different kind of Street smarts
than anybody we've met before she's from a very
rough neighborhood and then MIT so she's got to
deal with that polish versus Street there's so
much to this character and I think they nailed
it I personally am a big fan of Brian Michael
bennison iron Hearts I personally think Dominic
Thorne the moment she walked on stage at Comic-Con
I saw ironheart very excited to see more from her
she without again much screen time already made a
great impression she's number 62. ironheart coming
in at number 61. we just got her as a hero and
prior we'd loved her as Jane Foster that is the
Mighty Thor now this one's tricky because I love
Natalie Portman so much it's hard to separate
my problems with writing and directing from the
performance I think she is a comedic Powerhouse
if you've never seen any of her SNL work but some
of the comedy stylings of the movie themselves
didn't suit the MCU or Natalie Portman that said
I was so invested in Jane Foster that I would have
rather had a Jane Foster movie I would have rather
had the battle with cancer I would have rather had
you know scenes of her deciding to pick up the
hammer again I would have rather had her Heroes
Journey her discovering these powers and instead
it felt like obviously we've had four for four
movies we're following his journey and she was
popping up in moments as this new character and
yeah we'd lived with Jane Foster but I wanted more
Mighty Thor than fact that I wanted more Mighty
Thor puts her pretty high in this list because I
do think Jane Foster and Natalie Portman did what
they could with the time they had Mighty Thor all
right number 60. we got a guy that shouldn't died
we got a fella that uh was taken out too soon I
don't know if it was a personal Vendetta from John
Sweden or what but Quicksilver getting shot is
preposterous what Aaron Taylor Johnson was able to
do in his charm in his chemistry with his sister
you heard me in his ability to make every scene
with him be different and unique and go up against
an already in theaters Quicksilver Remember The
Days of Future Past sorry no remember the the
other X-Men movie came out right around the
same time as this so he had a very tall order Evan
Peters brought this very different Quicksilver and
this was an Avengers Quicksilver and it still felt
unique and special I didn't love the outfit but I
love the performance I love the heroism I love the
sacrifice I love that Pietro got to be a bit of a
punk but also a hero and that's the character had
a great time with him died too soon Quicksilver
Pietro 60. number 59 and we are going back to the
world of eternals with fastos now fastos is a key
anchor in this giant film fastos is the one that
makes the family feel like a family and that's in
him having a family and I loved how immediately
I loved him and his family I was so enamored by
what Brian Tyree Henry brought he's the inventor
and he invents this nuclear family and I love that
I love that we immediately want to know more about
how much influence he said in humanity I love how
immediately his selflessness goes against all of
his programming and everything he's been told to
do I love that he's always been about us and a
bit about the underdog been about the little guy
I am about fastos as a character and definitely in
this delivery definitely this performance I think
Brian Tyree Henry was a standout in a very stacked
cast and I think fastos was the heart of a very
very beautiful family that is the eternals love
this movie coming in at number 58 sticking with
eternals and this is my second favorite
Eternal yes there's like five of the nine
eternals on this list I love that movie but
this one is so important to me on the macro
scale because we look at Heroes and we think
of Heroes as being you know infallible in a
way we look at Heroes as unbreakable it's one
of the reasons I don't identify with Superman
as much I like when Heroes have flaws that I
can identify with and I never thought we'd get
a character identifying with mental health so
directly as Athena Athena's mental health was
her strength in the film and that was beautiful
if she didn't have those mental struggles she
wouldn't have been able to see what she saw and
that wouldn't have made the eternals aware of the
truth sometimes what people perceive as a weakness
is a strength and sometimes when people perceive
as mental health is their greatest strength this
character is very important to me as someone who
struggles with mental health this character is
very important to me as someone who thinks we
need more representation of characters like this
on screen and as someone who loves that Angelina
Jolie chose to play a character like this to put
her name behind something like this to bring that
movie star bravado Gusto gravitas whatever you
want to call it Angelina Jolie asthena is a really
important character and a very powerful character
loved her to death She's high up on this list
number 57 is Jack Russell AKA werewolf by Knight
World by night is a fascinating character because
you've got a mercenary thrown in over his head
at the top but then you add all the supernatural
elements and particularly in this case in this
adaptation you do all this in 47 minutes you're
empathetic to this character right away your
sympathetic throughout the entire transformation
and every time he's on screen you feel like
you're learning more of his history just through
his eyes you feel like you're getting more of the
character every single moment without gluttonous
expositionary dialogue there's so much going on
under the surface and in the dialogue you get a
rich tapestry of character in 47 minutes through
a performance World by night is awesome want more
number 56 I was wrong there's two more eternals
guys spoiler alert I like the eternals Makari
Makari is another great example of how you can
wheel build a character That's Unique correctly
this was a character who's deaf that doesn't feel
like it's some sort of uh inclusionary panhandling
this is a character that represents something to
people this is a character that people can look
to and go that's me on the screen and she does it
so magnificently so so deftly so so beautifully
the the choreography of her movements the way she
just moves through the frame this actress is able
to do so much and it's so beautiful and it's so
seemingly authentic to who she is the actress
and the character Makari has some of the best
action in the MCU that final action set piece I
don't care what flash footage you show me that
Makari stuff is so incredible and she stays so
passionate through the film and her relationship
with my number one internal who's coming up later
is also a key part of why I love that movie and
that wasn't even scripted those characters just
had great chemistry and when things like that
happen that's so real we're gonna have organic
relationships happen on set that cause Sparks
that cause on camera into on script into the movie
changes love that love Makari number 50 . I have a
character if you showed me the first one of these
movies I would never be like that's my guy please
turn it into my guy he is played by the director's
brother and he is craglin craiglin is fascinating
I don't know what it is about him I always want
more crackling on screen you got a cast of actors
that I know very well by the time you know these
movies are coming out you got Chris Pratt as a
movie star you got Zoe Saldana who's like in the
biggest movies ever between Avatar and the Marvel
Universe these are these are Titans and I'm like
James Gunn's brother he's got something going on
you tell me more about Shang gun Annie's Rocket's
body like he's walking around like this guy does
so much and there's something just so interesting
about how Earnest he is like the ravagers have
something so us about them there's this Underdog
thing to the Guardians for sure they're the the
a-holes of the universe but the ravagers are just
like getting by man and cragland's just one of the
guys getting by he's that mechanic you trust and I
love that craglin 55 at number 54 you're probably
wondering hey why'd you talk about werewolf by
night you didn't talk about man thing well that's
because he's higher up because man thing is not
only a thing I never thought would work but not
only did he work he kind of became the MVP of this
movie he has moments where his power is terrifying
but you still want to hug him his beautiful like
elephant eyes that are so you're enamored you're
you're pulled into him and yet he's a creature
that warps reality and you don't know a lot about
him but you know you want to know more he doesn't
really speak you have to talk through jack russell
to understand what's going on his name's Ted which
is delightful I just everything about him is great
and as far as heroism he's a cornered animal and
he still doesn't attack people until he needs to
and that's impressive this is something that's
been chased his whole life he's been seen as a
monster he's been seen as a beast and he still
has a sense of humor he's still as a best friend
he's still able to see the good in things and
that's that's all we can hope for really number 53
I'm gonna get some crap for this I'm gonna take a
little sip I'm excited for her to be hired I'm
excited for the movie she gets this year where
I hope she's higher and uh you know the movie made
a billion dollars it wasn't for me and that means
it was for a lot of people which is great I'm
happy when something makes money that isn't for
me because a lot of artists got paid I love I'll
say the word love I love Brie Larson the actress
the person I like Captain Marvel the character the
hero I have not seen those come together yet I've
seen tastes I've seen pieces and I love the pieces
enough that they're this High 53 is an optimistic
53's belief in the future but I didn't feel the
Charisma that Brie Larson has coming out through
Captain Marvel I didn't feel the Charming stoicism
that Captain Marvel has coming out through the
character I I feel like there's some Block in the
middle I can see the pieces I am very excited for
them to come together number 52 is the second
iteration of character the first of which got an
honorable mention I said Hank and Janet at the top
honorable mention this is wasp now Evangeline Lily
is one of those actresses that whenever she shows
up you're interested she just has that movie star
quality that said I put her this low in the list
because the entire first movie spends a lot of the
time going hey I could do this better hey why are
we training this guy hey I can do this better and
it took until the second movie for her get to do
that that's not her fault but it definitely made
me feel like this sense of frustrated stagnation
about the character because it's like I feel like
wasp but wouldn't have taken no for an answer like
she wouldn't have listened to people being like
you sit down and that's not fair to the character
but it's also not fair to where to put her on this
list because I didn't get that until the second
movie the second movie She's exceptional I'm very
excited for the scales to balance and for her to
get to be two-thirds of the time awesome but that
first movie is really frustrating seeing her not
get to be why wasp and play a sidekick she's not
a sidekick it's Ant-Man and the WASP they're on
the same type level and there she is I'm excited
to see more of that number 51 is a guy who was
miscast because he should have been a lead and
that Cass is a supporting part and I was like
don't you do that he's Idris Elba heimdell is
awesome heimdell could have been Thor heimdell is
a force of Nature and heimdell Andy driselba both
deserve better I just feel like heimdell when
he shows up I'm always there uh you know Thor
Ragnarok he gets some really badass action scenes
which is why he's as high up as he is a lot of
this is Idris Elba love I'll totally own that a
lot of this is just me being a big fan of Idris
Elba I wish that I could put heimdell in the top
50 and that's Baby Wise 51 so I'm like my guy the
character in the comic books is between one note
and fascinating like they don't give him a lot of
time but when he gets time to dive in you're like
this guy I feel the same buddy Idris elba's taking
the character whenever they let Idris Play I'm all
in and and he got more screen time throughout the
movies spoiler alert for a movie from the summer
the post credit scene I was like oh good they
realize how great Easter zombies heimdell is but
I just felt like it was too little too late give
me give me a another world where he plays Thor
himself and I'm only or you just Zelda or him now
actually matter of fact you bring back Idris Elba
as Beta Ray Bill as the voice of Beta Ray Bill and
you solve all these problems keep them on the
payroll keep him in Asgard number 50 is the one
that's gonna get a lot of people upset with me but
hey it means comments in the chat it means Greg's
happy it sucks all the things it is Spider-Man
Toby Maguire you heard me Spider-Man Toby
McGuire okay so what heroes are is people that go
through arcs and gret what I struggle with with
the original Sam Raimi topangaire films is that
he stays angry and so the Nerds when they react
to things there's there's nerds that get even
and there's nerds that realize that they don't
have to get even you have people that are like I'm
gonna get my bullies back in 20 years and there's
people that are like I'm gonna actually go be a
successful CEO and forget the dude that peaked
in high school I think the way that Toby played
Spider-Man was the dude that's gonna have revenge
on Flash Thompson in 20 years it's not healthy
he cheats on Mary Jane he kisses Gwen Stacy in
front of Mary Jane he upside down kisses he does
the trademark thing we all love from the first
film to cheat on the woman of his dreams I get you
have to introduce Gwen Stacy I get you've got to
grow the character cast out but that is the least
authentic Spider-Man thing ever the reason Peter
Parker the nerdy guy that's so charming and good
at science has all these beautiful women around
him in the comic books is because he respects them
all and all these women realize how rare that is
what is Toby McGuire's Peter Parker do disrespects
Mary Jane to her face I don't I don't like it I
don't feel good about it but I will say in no way
home they redeem it in no way home he addresses
all that he talks about how he uh has had to work
on some things he's a much more mature take in the
character the Tobey Maguire in no way home is
much more than Peter Parker I always hoped he'd
be by the third film and eventually got to be
so it is higher than it might you know would be
otherwise without knowing home and it's on this
list because of no way home because that's the
MCU inclusion so I will respect fleeks I know
a lot of people love those films it's just not
my characterization and it does demean the heroic
aspects and certain elements of what Spider-Man is
the train scene notwithstanding that some heroism
obviously but everyone knows his identity anyway
Spider-Man number 50. all right I got that off
my chest number 49 Agent Phil Coulson I am gonna
take this uh you know the MCU route and uh it's
gonna be just the movies I consider Phil Coulson
to have died in The Avengers because they needed
something to avenge I respect Agents of Shield but
I'm only going off he got so many great moments
in the movies and that's that's what I love is
if you have a character die in the course of
Duty and literally be the thing that names The
Avengers that's about as heroic as it gets that
is beautiful writing that is a reason for these
characters names that gives you a very unique MCU
flavor there is no Phil Coulson in the comic books
there is no we need to avenge singular character
I love that they focused in on this one wonderful
man masterfully played by Clark reg as this take
on the character I I think he's he's perfect uh
from the trading cards to the use of the trading
cards as something to avenge like everything about
this character is is Pitch Perfect earlier in
the in the movie uh the movies when when you
don't have a first name your first name is Agent
there's just so much about this character that is
so beautifully sterile government but every time
you see a little bit of fill you're really happy
about it Andy's a hero to sacrifice himself love
me some Phil Coulson number 49 just above Phil
Coulson is the great Maria hill now she is in the
comic books and she's someone who I always saw
as a great asset amongst the shield chess pieces
and then they cast Kobe smolders and she brought
so much more than a chess piece I mean I'd watch
a Maria Hill movie and I would not have said that
before seeing what Kobe's Boulders brought to this
role I want to see a spy movie with Maria Hill I
want to see what she thinks of the Segovia Accords
I want to see what she thinks of kamala's law if
that goes forward I want to see what she thinks of
the the She-Hulk legislation that's going to pass
I'm so curious about this human amongst Gods now
that's more DC's thing right like where they put
you know us here and the eye line is up at these
Gods but Maria Hill's a great example so is Phil
Coulson of what it's like to have regular people
around metahumans and how they can be heroes too
and that's what makes her so special 48. coming
in at number 47 is another Eternal I realize there
are a lot of eternals in this list that the cast
is huge but this one I thought they did a really
cool job making him feel like he's part of the
world the tapestry of the world and making him
the most Marvel character in this very Art House
film that is Kingo I think Kingo has played did a
lot of heavy lifting comedically but also didn't
really let off the drama you still cared about
this character and I love the idea of him playing
his own grandson him playing like his self Through
the Ages and it shows what a more immortality
would be like in reality in a really cool way and
it also shows what it'd be like to be trapped in
that that running joke of your own life and to do
all those things and then when they Incorporated
him into Miss Marvel when they made him a broader
Hero on the world stage it just made him such
an interesting character to me so it was it was
Camille's portrayal and then Miss Marvel that
really elevated him to this point so uh we got
Kingo pretty high at number 47 number 46 Monica
Rambo Now One Division season was quite a long
time ago and when it was one division season
we all sat strapped to our chairs wrapped that
attention at this new thing what was this MCU show
what were these Mysteries what's going on and a
huge part of that and a lot of people remember you
know the the Wanda and vision of One Division but
Monica Rambo comic fans knew she became Spectrum
or Photon depending on which continuity and a
lot of fan know that she's a Captain Marvel we we
had that and we were like when's it gonna happen
what's going on is that gonna be another follow-up
what's she was part of the mystery in the Intrigue
but what made this portrayal so interesting was
she was day to day in Wanda's Life as a best
friend and I completely bought they might just
have that be the character I thought what if they
changed comic continuity and Wanda invented this
person I thought what if she's an agent of shield
and this is real and then they they still managed
to make a new and inventive reality manipulation
by way of Wanda origin for this character that's
totally unique Canon to the MCU that works I think
better in a lot of ways because now it makes
sense she's Photon look at the reality look at
the imagery look at all the things they did and
the characterization the delivery the Friendship
the portrayal I bought all of it love this take
and I cannot wait for the Marvels in part because
of how great Monica Rambo was not to mention not
to mention the daughter thing we met her young
in Captain Marvel what a great way to tie in all
those elements man I really dug that the daughter
of the character met before as played by Lashana
Lynch that element where you use time travel in
a linear time way endearing as to the character
without even having better genius there's so many
elements of this character I dig all right into
our top 45 and this is a character that had a
lot to do and actually got moved movies for her
introduction which I can't imagine as an actor
having to do America's Chavez America Chavez we
were supposed to get no way home she was supposed
to open the portals to bring in the Spiderman but
then she was moved to Doctor Strange coveted stuff
happened not Shenanigans ensued and she was able
to do so much while basically being an exposition
Chase character she runs throughout this whole
movie and the charm of Sochi Gomez is what makes
this work if you had a lesser actress in this
role if you had a less interesting character
in this movie it doesn't work this this perfect
storm of what America Chavez had to be immediately
endeared to this new character immediately
curious in this young Avenger I want to see
the Young Avengers in part because of shochi's
performance and there are definitely flaws uh
the the exposition moment with the memory dump
did not work for me but she recovered from it the
character worked and I want more for so uh America
shot that's 45 number 44 and okay this is the last
Eternal I promise I got a lot of biases here uh
one I love the actor playing him two it was great
to hear an Irish accent in the MCU and three
I love the idea of humanity being what's more
important free will or happiness druig is that
as a hero and he's an anti-hero just like he is
in the comic books druig is not someone you trust
druk's not someone you like but you like him in
the movie in part because of a relationship with
Makari in part because Barry kejone is a goddamn
Mastermind of an actor and in part because you
kind of identify with where he's coming from the
opiate of the masses the the concept of just being
like screw it just guide me through this world I
don't want to make decisions it's hard to be a
person and he was right in a lot of ways that it
is nice to just not have to make decisions how
great is it when sometimes someone makes dinner
for you and just a surprise don't worry about
it here's dinner he did that for an entire cult
and he made him happy is that good no it's no free
will it's a great great question I'm not saying I
agree with Colts I'm not saying I agree with mind
washing but brainwashing but I am saying it's a
fascinating character and at the end of the day he
chose the right thing that's what makes him a hero
at the end of the day he chose the side of freeing
people of letting humans make their own decisions
and uh Barry Keon man love this guy number 44
druick number 43 is higher up than she would have
been even a month ago because she finally got her
time in the Sun and that is mantis thanks to the
holiday special mantis hadn't gotten a lot of her
own solo time she hadn't got a lot of Spotlight
time but when she did it shown why Palm clementif
was cast like this was just a pumpkin show the
holiday special was to show how incredible Palm
was not only is she to make childlike Wonder not
boring or childish or one note but she's able
to make it what we want to see the world as and
what better place than a Christmas special right
that wonders of Christmas but she's always trying
to do the right thing like she she doesn't want
to hurt anyone she endures going through the the
horrors of Thanos she puts herself In Harm's Way
She sacrifices a lot she wants Peter Quill to be
happy even at her own guilt she shoulders the
knowledge of the twist of holiday special for
Peter she's a hero always sacrificing always
looking out for others always taking care of
others while being adorable endearing and great
comedically love me semantis I'm so glad the
holiday special gave her time to shine number 42
is the wonderful the captivating the Charming the
interesting the Tatiana maslani She-Hulk this one
was hard to rank because frankly episodes one and
two and eight and nine of shulk are some of my
favorite MCU the middle I did struggle through
and I understand why some elements in the middle
were written the way they were because of episodes
eight and nine but that doesn't change the fact
that I don't don't feel like we got enough of the
the intelligence of Shield we didn't get enough
of the witty in court drama of Shield we saw a
lot with Daredevil certainly we saw shield and
Daredevil exchange witty barbs but what she elk
represents is being more intelligent than so many
people including sometimes the audience I would
love to in a season two see more of that in the
courtroom it's an anti-trolling Choice which I
respect because trolls can off but it is also a
choice that puts us in a position of not knowing
where to put her as a hero she didn't actually
have a villain to fight she had the concept of
trolls to fight when she has to fight the leader
when she has to do these things I'm very excited
for it we did see elements we did see her fighting
alongside Wong we did see her do heroic things
which is why she's as high as she is and because
I love the character and because she was truly
again Charming intelligent fun pithy all the
things you want from Shield I just really need
to see a little bit more to put her any higher
that said she's very high she's about halfway up
because I love me some shield and I really think
they nailed a near impossible character if you'd
asked me a list of 10 impossible Marvel characters
to translate she elk would absolutely have been on
that and they did it coming in at number 41. okay
this is uh this is a fun one because I would not
have ever expected this character to make this
list up until the year the show came out I think
it was last year Mobius is not a character that
I go man I want me some Mobius television Owen
Wilson is not a character I would have thought
man I want me some Owen Wilson in the MCU I love
Owen Wilson I just would never have thought his
Wes Anderson wow of goodness would fit and yet I
have never wanted anything more than to see a man
on a jet ski and that is the power of Owen Wilson
as Mobius Mobius is lawful good to the level
that it's the perfect counter to Loki Loki is
a bad guy gone good you need that lawful good to
counter him lawful good is the least interesting
thing I don't usually again I bring up Superman I
don't usually get enthralled by Superman comics I
don't usually invest in the world of lawful good
it's not my thing Mobius is somehow so good and
so right and so charming and so Owen Wilson that
he's number 41 Mobius it is a mobin time is it
guys number 41 it's mobin time all right top 40.
we are about halfway we got Nakia Nakia from the
Black Panther movies is so I keep using the
word captivating but I think this is the most
captivating a character has been with what
she does in every frame well Appia Nyong'o
one of the most stunning people to ever exist
in a character that has to be that she's a spy
she's an ambassador she is a representative of her
country she cares about everyone the citizens the
very people of the country she doesn't want to
get caught up in the the king queen Madness she
doesn't want to deal with the world she wants
to know t'challa not King t'challa and somehow
they're able to do that and they're able to
translate that and she's able to be seen as
nothing but heroic nothing but helpful in the
second movie you find out she's sacrificed even
going to t'challa's funeral in order to protect
the secret of Prince t'challa that's heroic that's
selfless that's beautiful and to do it while
helping people in Haiti to do it while being
on the ground on the Forefront on the front lines
of helping people that need it most beautiful I
just like that's a hero and and maybe of of the
characters I've talked about so far like maybe
the most real hero like people that are helping
people in Haiti people that are feeding people
that people that are making sure that citizens
of countries are are okay those are heroes and
Nakia man what a what a role what a hero what
a performance number 39 we got Moon Knight okay
so Moon night's tricky because I love this show
until the last episode last episode wasn't even
that bad but it did the thing that she all made
fun of with the giant Marvel fight problem so
it's really hard for me to uh separate my feeling
of how the show left me feeling versus how I felt
during the show I Remember Loving the show watched
it here with the guys we had a great time and I
remember being like Oh my God they did it they
made Moon night how are they doing this I think
Moon Knight might be some of the best acting in
the MCU I think Oscar Isaac's portrayal of Moon
Knight is absolutely and I think the unique aspect
of my criteria is absolutely here I think it's
one of the most unique characters I think it's
one of the most unique portrayals things one of
those unique shows I think we saw him be heroic I
think we also saw him be not heroic which also is
interesting to give you the dichotomy The Duality
it's also a character that we don't necessarily
have a guarantee of getting more of we've heard
season two sure but I want to see more of him
before I really decide where he goes he was very
consciously right in the middle because I love
Moon Knight I never thought we'd see him he's
alongside shield in that 10 character I never
thought we'd see but I don't know how I feel about
where I left him and that's not the character's
fault so as far as the characters portrayed I give
him a very high B which is in this mid-range love
me some Moon number 38 is wongalicious uh Wong
has in phase four gotten so much more screen time
for good reason Wong is effectively her Nick Fury
right now recruiting what's either going to be the
dark Avengers or the Young Avengers we'll see but
what is so great about Wong is he always makes the
right move but he always does it begrudgingly
I love that Wong always wants a sandwich more
than he wants to fight the bad guys and I also
love that he'll always fight the bad guys this
is a guy that we met basically guarding the the
sacred books at karmotage listening to Beyonce
and that's that's a Bop right there that's a man
that knows taste eloquence and had to be the right
guy on the right side of the line and then we
get endeared to him he's the classic character
that like is stiff and stoic and breaks and you
fall in love with him and we absolutely have
and to this point he's watching Breaking Bad so
I don't know he's a very human character to be
the master of the Mystic Arts he's also one of the
most powerful characters in the MCU and Benedict
Wong makes him personable and that's what you
want to hear number 37 now we're getting to the
point where this is a struggle I think from I mean
really from 40 up it was it was Nakia could be in
the top 30. Moon Knight could be in the top like
once you get past 40 it is is anyone's game but
now it's real real hard because 37 Kevin Smith's
number here Peggy Carter is a character I've Loved
from the beginning Peggy Carter is a character
who is not as to me interesting in the comic books
Peggy Carter serves as a North star for Steve
Rogers she so much more than that here they made
her a leader they made her someone fighting on the
front lines they made her Agent Carter they made
her everything that Steve is in a no disrespect
Chris Evans even more beautiful package I am so
enamored by Haley Atwell because she's able to
be so Regal and so eloquent and so a woman of a
bygone era while still being a modern badass like
there's something just so timelessly captivating
about Haley Atwell which is the only way to play
this part this is a woman out of time this is a
woman we see in her 80s dying in Steve Rogers
arms that we have to care for in the 40s a time
that none of us lived I mean someone watching this
might be 90. hello 90 year old what was it like
but overall that's not an experience we have and
yet there's something about it that makes us feel
like she's from the 40s and then when you've got
Agent Carter you have to immediately be endeared
to her we get no origin for her we just know she's
awesome and she is I don't know there's something
about uh Haley Atwell and there's something about
Peggy Carter that I really love and it is to me
Superior than the comic take which puts her pretty
high 30 number 36 we're into the other team we got
through the eternals now we're into the Guardians
we are going with Gamora Gamora has a very hard
job she is an alien assassin that Star-Lord falls
in love with Star-Lord basically is our eye line
into this crazy universe and so we love Gamora and
that's a very hard role to play a character that
has all of her own backstory with Thanos with her
journey and everything else but is also the object
of affection if you watch ROM columns a lot of
time either the male or the female is underwritten
whoever's being pursued is often a little less
of an intricate character not as bad as it used
to be than the the pursuer and that can easily
happen in a role like this and they didn't ever
let that happen you're always as fascinated by
Gamora as your Star-Lord her backstory is arguably
even more interesting even though the film opens
on star-lord's backstory she's also green it's a
character that doesn't we don't identify like
it's a literal alien character but what Zoe
Saldana brings is this this incredible openness
this incredible Wonder this incredible sense of
even when she's under duress you want to help she
wants to do the right thing even though everything
in her programming says not to she's the daughter
of Thanos and she got out to help people even if
some of it's self-serving she's a guardian the
Galaxy for a reason and I'm really excited to
see what they do in three with this new timeline
Gamora why is Gamora indeed all right we're gonna
stick with the Guardians of the Galaxy and go with
number 35. now this one's tricky because this is a
giant change from the comics and I like them both
sometimes comic changes are for the better like I
think Peggy Carter is a better character than she
is in the comic books Drax I think is great in
both iterations Drax is a Jim Starlin character
who's a lot more vicious in the comic books but
I think this really fun literal take is so useful
because he's never dumb he's literal he's it's a
very unique kind of Comedy sometimes it goes a
little far I do think that in in one of the in
game or Avengers Infinity War um the the Frozen
scene is a bit much there are moments that go
a little far but overall the way he's written
allows you to feel a different kind of humor
that you need the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
are brutal they are emotionally devastating and
without characters like Drax to bring you back to
have that whole relief of a laugh in the middle of
a cry you're out so I think Drax in this form is
absolute what it needs to be and he's coming all
from a place of heartbreak the heroism is you
know Thanos destroyed his whole family all of
this is a Revenge tale and that could be so boring
and so one note but it never becomes one note or
boring because what Dave Batista does with the
character Dave Batista makes you feel every bit
of his loss of family while making you laugh with
him not at him and that's a hard thing to do and
he's never not a hero no decision he makes even
when he's being selfish somehow doesn't serve
others which is also a hard thing to do love me
some Drax number 34 sticking with them Guardians
we got one of the MVPs as far as acting goes in
the entire MCU there's a lot of incredible acting
against MCU I think Oscar Isaac is definitely a
highlight I think when we get to the top ten I'm
not going to give my top 10 away but a lot of
those are highlights but this one was hard to
not put any higher out of sheer Talent of acting
it's just screen time and that is nebula nebula
is in every movie The Scene stealer Ace you watch
end game and everyone is going through trauma and
there's something about what Karen Gillen brings
while covered in makeup with these giant black
eyes that you just want to help so badly she's
so tortured so broken so her hero's journey is
coming from a place like a lot of people are
like six feet under she's like 20 feet under
she has no reason to want to help anyone she
has no reason to be in any way endearing but
that fight between her and nebula in Guardians 2
is so painful because you feel the punish twice
every blow that lands you feel for nebula and
Gamora and I don't know how nebula manages to
be so interesting every time how much pain you
could feel for this character but she always does
the thing that's gonna make you feel for her and
she still does I don't know I just I love nebula
so much that's another whole video nebulous great
number 33 is a character that immediately stole
my heart he has a character from the comic books
that they literally don't even refer to as the
name because it is so outdated and doesn't work at
all maku is not a character I ever thought would
be like that's the guy from the comic to the
screen Winston Duke makes this character work
and they have so many details that tie into his
original name by the way is manape manape does
not work maku is a character who is leading a
rival tribe and as a rival is never quite an
antagonist you don't ever have anything against
this guy you understand where he's coming from in
the movie Black Panther everyone's perspective is
is fair to a point even killmonger's worldview is
pretty much just an American world view so you
really need to have lots of nuance and I think
Baku has the most nuanced perspective outside
of t'challa and that's that's the strength of
the character is he's protecting his people
he's protecting wakanda even though he's been
ostracized out to the mountains and then to tie
in the comic elements like you know he's eating a
vegetable in the second movie as a comedic element
but it's also like a favorite vegetable of Apes so
they make it a man ape thing it's just it's genius
when they've done this character genius how human
they've made a supporting character and how much
you want more of him uh I'll take an embaku movie
tomorrow sign me up Winston Duke please number
32 okay so you've got the original Avengers right
you've got the the ogs in the first film you've
got the six they all got a tattoo together when
you're replacing any of those six you are screwed
like how are you going to replace Captain America
well you got Sam Wilson how are you going to
replace Thor we don't even know yet how are you
gonna replace Iron Man we talked about ironheart
earlier it's not easy Hawkeye gave a whole show
six hours for Kate Bishop who you may know we
haven't talked about yet I was like man how are
they possibly going to replace one of the first
to die Black Widow is a very beloved character
and Yelena balova is another assassin and it's
all Florence Pew man Florence Pew is immediately
captivating I mean that's that's the subtitles
video top 75 Heroes captivating but Jolina bolova
is so much every time she's on screen she's funny
she's terrifying you wanna hate her but you can't
she's the sister you don't want but love it's
exactly what she needed to be and that's the
only way we can get another Black Widow in the
universe if you're gonna have another Russian
Assassin from the Red Room that doesn't feel like
a copycat I can think of no other way and the fact
that she's had such beautiful Redemption so far
the fact that she's done so much heroic already
in her limited appearances such a hero such
a Titan love me some Elena bilova number 30.
two number 31 maybe the person with the least
screen time in the top almost 30. we're getting
again into the I could have moved anyone around
here this one is the she gets she gets pretty
high up because of the oh my God how did they
do this of it all Elsa Bloodstone has like 20
minutes of screen time most of which are in black
and white I'm more invested in the future of what
Elsa Bloodstone does in the MCU then some of the
characters you met 14 years ago I don't know how
they did this but a character that's literally
a monster hunter from the comics a very one note
every 90s let's show some boobs character that
doesn't really get a lot of stretch well that's
all she does is stretch she doesn't have the
character integrity that you'd want a full-fledged
lead to have immediately Giver in werewolf by
night you care about her family you care about her
history you care that she was mistreated you care
about what Monster hunting she's gonna get into
you wanted to get the Bloodstone you want her to
treat Ted with respect and she does you care about
like she her son are incredible the physicality
of Elsa bloodstreet I loved her choreography as
well as the portrayal I don't know uh 20 minutes
of screen time or so Elsa Bloodstone is is number
31 lover coming in at number 30 is an actress that
I did not know before the Black Panther movies but
now we'll watch anything she does deny Guerrera
is a Powerhouse I love Okoye so much Okoye she
makes so many decisions that I should hate she
sides with killmonger she stays a loyal Trooper
she just does she's U.S agent she just does as
she's told she just listens to the badge I'm
not a fan of that in Life or in characters and
yet Okoye is so great and so fascinating and I
get it I see where she's coming from the dorm
Elijah swear an oath and she abides by that
oath so much so that in the second film I think
the best scene in the film is her versus Angela
Bassett in a battle of just sheer willpower and an
emotion and loss and what's honorable is leaving
the staff and leaving your post and that's what
she does because she's honorable every decision
she makes is about honor and that's in incredible
and it's never boring and sometimes that can be in
a character akoye is such a boss I love her a lot
number 30. coming in at number 29 is a character
that made a giant mistake which cost us half the
people in the universe but that's human and he's
half human Star-Lord I do feel like gets a lot of
oh my God why would he do that because that's the
character you need to factor in the emotion of
humanity the human element of these Heroes is
so important and that's what separates these
characters from a lot of other characters and
that's what separates this universe I think that
a lot of other shared universes the human element
and a lot of times you need Star-Lord for that
look at the Guardians of the Galaxy they're all
aliens very clearly look at them star-lords are
our Island I said that earlier about Gamora if
he hadn't been so emotionally invested in Gamora
and punch Thanos it wouldn't have felt authentic
I think that was one of the most heroic things he
did and it wasn't heroic it was human and that's
heroic being a person feeling your emotions it's
important and and I I don't know some about that
moment also you know all the Guardians movies him
being great him being our Island him being funny
him being Charming him saving the universe
him having to dance off for heroism but that
moment that a lot of people hate I think is really
important so it's the main thing I'm focusing on
here Star Lord's number 29 for a bevy of reasons
but uh I love me some some bold characterization
through emotion coming in at number 28 is our
new Captain America Sam Wilson as the Falcon
dude had to endure a lot of on your left he had to
be number two he had to be a soldier he had to say
yes sir and answer to things even when he didn't
necessarily think it was right but when he knew it
was wrong he didn't blindly do things and I think
that's what makes a hero I think that's what's
really important about the character is he has a
very important set of morals and ethics I loved
the characterization we got with him Falcon Winter
Soldier I love getting to see his family I love
that they use Anthony Mackey's Origins instead
of the comic book Origins because you don't have
to be beholden to the comic books I love when
things work I love when you can translate the
comic books but I think making it about Anthony
Mackey's New Orleans was much more captivating
than just following a comic book it felt more
real felt more Earnest and the human element
of Sam Wilson is what makes him Captain America
Bucky should never have been given the shield
in the MCU it makes sense in the comic books what
they did made sense but we saw through the course
of seven movies or whatever why it deserved to be
Sam Wilson he didn't need to be in therapy like
Bucky did he didn't have the trauma that Bucky
did or he was able to handle the trauma better
than Bucky did he was always the right man for
the job that's not an easy role to be the right
man to take over something to be the number two
he's always been the number two and that is not
an easy role to fill without feeling like a junior
without feeling like a lesser Anthony Mackey did a
very very great job at becoming the man that would
become Captain America and I'm excited to see him
in those wings coming in at number 27 one of my
favorite new characters in the comic books one
of my favorite young actresses working and one of
my favorite portrayals of said character as actor
Kate Bishop is Hawkeye this this was a show that I
loved and then it just fell apart for me in such a
way that it breaks my heart to this day I still
think it's one of the best action set pieces in
the entire MCU is that uh that bow and arrow down
the highway the the chase sequence with the car
is is staggering but what makes Kate Bishop so
interesting is she's us in a less specific way
than Miss Marvel we have a character in Miss
Marvel that is literally literally us right a
fangirl a Die Hard notice she's not been on the
list yet she's coming okay Bishop's the underdog
in another kind of way she's rich but doesn't feel
welcome she doesn't have a place she belongs it's
so hard to write a rich character as an underdog
and they do it she doesn't belong because she
doesn't identify with these people she doesn't
fit into this world and she wants to help more
than she wants to just be rich that's hard and
that's that's a hero to to sacrifice the easy way
out to do the hard thing is a hero and hailee
Steinfeld nailed that I I was immediately so
fascinated by this take in the character because
it felt so akin to the comic but in a new medium
like I could hear the words that were written
by Matt fraction I could hear the comic book
come to life but Haley Steinfeld was exactly it
to a level that I didn't expect to work because
I've talked about adaptation for this translation
it almost felt like a translation but it was the
perfect adaptation love Haley Seinfeld SK Bishop
number 26 we're almost there in that top 25 is
Mary Poppins y'all yandu isn't your father but he
is your daddy this is one of the great sacrifices
in modern superhero films I love the father
betrayal and then Redemption of star-lord's whole
thing man uh the loss of parents is a very big
Marvel Trope uh comic book Trope but it's really
well done here with yondu fatherhood isn't uh just
about blood being someone's dad is not about just
blood it's it's who raises you who takes care of
you who is there for you as that paternal figure
and you would never have thought we'd get from
where we meet yondu in Guardians 1 to where we
end with yondu and Guardians too ever I would
never have seen that Arc being so beautiful
and that's Michael Rooker man self-sacrifice
for your child is about as heroic As It Gets
Mary Poppins yell number 26 Yonder coming in
at number 25 is the man that brought them all
together the man who was gonna instigate that
Avengers Initiative the great Nick Fury so Nick
Fury is spy extraordinaire but he's also a man
who is always going to do the right thing he is
a man that'll dismantle Shield he's a man that
doesn't trust anybody he trusted someone once
and it was a cat we learned later on but he he's
always the guy that's gonna do the right thing and
that's what heroes are it's great because Samuel
Jackson is the guy that's always yelling and you
know known for his excellent use of four letter
words but there's something inherently Charming
about Nick Fury and Samuel Jackson portrayal of
them that you trust him even though all things say
you shouldn't like he's literally a guy carrying
a gun and like all leather like a matrix villain
and yet you're like this guy I think Nick Fury
is a fascinating take in the character I think
they elevated the 70s Nick Fury and the Howling
Commandos of it all into a real character he feels
fleshed out got a lot of love for him coming in
at number 24 is the original Groot remember baby
Groot is a new Groot this is OG root this is the
Groot that died in Guardians 1 and that's a huge
part of this uh we talk about heroic sacrifices
I think one of the greatest lines in the MCU is
we are group we have a character that only
can say one thing and remember this is the
only alternate thing he ever said because every
other line from either root as so far has been
I am Groot but to this point we'd only ever heard
these amazing different portrayals by Vin Diesel
these different deliveries these different ways
of expression through I am Groot and then we are
Groot is what the Guardians is about they're a
family they unite and it's through the sacrifice
of group they're able to survive it's a beautiful
moment it's the definition of heroism and it's
from a giant talking tree I I've said it so many
times but I remember when Guardians was announced
it was the first time I was worried something
a bit dignified everyone was complaining about
Age of Ultron like oh they're using Pinocchio in
the trailer I didn't care about that it was the
idea that there was gonna be a talking raccoon
a talking tree I was like ah this looks maybe
they're selling toys I was so wrong I didn't
know James guns work that well at this point
I was a fool this tree taught me to love again
groups number 24. number 23 is a character that
I feel like was perhaps the most shortchanged of
the entire Thor family and that's saying something
because you know my thoughts on Jane Foster
and how much I love her I feel like lady Sif is
so good every time she's on screen to the point
of making Thor dark World watchable the love
triangle in Thor dark World is more interesting
than a lot of the other relationships in Marvel
and that is I think still the worst of the Marvel
films but the dynamic between lady Sif who is the
god element of Thor and Jane Foster who is the
Mortal element of Thor being at conflict only
works because of how fascinating Jamie Alexander
is Natalie Portman's obviously who we know he's
going to end up with in love triangles usually
one character isn't interesting The Notebook
James Marsden is so interesting but you know it's
gonna be Ryan Gosling you don't really invest in
James Marsden that man needs a better team because
he should be a giant star James Martin's a huge
star but he should be Ryan Gosling I digress but
you know what I'm saying like when you watch The
Notebook you're not like I'm gonna go on the James
Marsden journey I want to know everything about
Jamie Alexander's lady Sif also I would say before
Wonder Woman came out some of the best female lead
fight scenes she's incredible on the battlefield
she's the character I wanted back most when she's
just disappeared from Thor Ragnarok it was the
character I was the most upset with being you
know shortchanged in love and thunder and that's
saying something Jamie Alexander is so I'm gonna
say it Captivate 23. coming in at number 22 is Don
Cheadle as war machine will include Terence Howard
for the arc but is Don Cheadle and that's actually
a huge part of this is when you take over a role
from someone else after they've been the origin
of the character after they're introduced they
literally have a line that's next time baby like
we know war machines coming from the first Iron
Man and it's still exciting every time the secret
Invasion trailer is in part so interesting because
of the sheer depth of knowledge of what Colonel
Rhodes has behind his eyes he knows so much more
than he lets on and it never feels nefarious he's
a hero that keeps his cards to the chest but not
in a spy way because that's Nick Fury it's a
guy that just doesn't trust the institutions
that he was handed to and I love that conflict
the conflict of Colonel Rhodes as a colonel
dealing with the military and being an honorable
member of the military while Tony's doing all this
reckless [__] that's their whole that's their
Brotherhood and that doesn't work if the actor and
the character don't still feel like they can stand
their own two legs we should have had an Iron Man
4 slash War Machine years ago we're getting armor
worse it's well overdue this character can stand
in his own two legs when he's been a sidekick for
so long much like Bucky like this is a Powerhouse
character that's been like right over here finally
getting his time in the sun I I really think he's
such a noble hero and and you know I've got my
own issues with the militarization of choices but
I think that the Marvel Cinematic Universe could
have become way too like gung-ho recruitment video
if it wasn't for the nuanced take of Colonel
Rhodes with Don Cheadle 22. all right number
21 this one's hard man 21 is a character that
I really like in the comics that I like in the
movies but I do acknowledge is probably the
most different in how I think of them between
the movies and the comics in a more negative way
top three are all all characters that I think
are improvements from the comic books this one
is a slight demerit but it's more of a lateral
move it's not it's not lesser it's just lateral
I think the Hulk has been too teamified if you
look at Ed Norton's Hulk it's a very independent
character The Incredible Hulk was able to be his
own man I think that Mark ruffalo's Hulk though
always interesting is only an object of the team
Dynamic and that's hard because I know Universal
has rights issues and there's problems there with
how to get that movie out and I respect that and
I'm not blaming anyone but it always feels like
Mark Ruffalo as the Hulk is a character that
has to serve the greater MCU and that's really
ironic considering the Hulk is the thing that
destroys the MCU you know in The Avengers The
Hulk is fighting alongside them at at the final
battle but like you know we we see him getting
you know messed up and brainwashed delightfully
and in age of all trying to get to see the Hulk
again but we don't get to see the Hulk smash
in a way that feels authentic to the Hulk
again in like 10 years so there's just something
about the portrayal of the Hulk that I really
that's what I'm trying to say we're at 7 8 of an
arc I think when this lands and we get like World
breaker hope and we get more of the the aggressive
portrayal of the Hulk like in the comic books it's
gonna Feel Complete so he's this High because
there's so much potential and because I love the
character and nothing is wrong I've seen nothing
wrong there's nothing I'm saying is negative
that's why again this is really high in the list
this is almost top 20. I just feel like it's not
complete yet and I think when it's complete it
could be top like 15 maybe even top 10 depending
on how they stick that Landing but I do feel like
there's a piece of Hulk missing and I'm excited to
see that get filled the top 20 of 75 characters
this list is long we got the only person that
could take over a very very very impossible mantle
we got a character that is a Legacy character in
the comic books but we didn't know if that
was going to land as a Legacy character in
the movies we have a very Charming very funny very
quippy sidekick sister ensuring in the first black
panther shuri is a highlight because she's a lot
of the levity like that movie's fun for sure but
a lot of the quips a lot of the dialogue a lot of
that like what are those uh of the movie are shuri
and that's her in the comics a lot of the time
but she's also a Regal ass Warrior she's a badass
the characters Arc in the second movie is kind
of the great Arc of the fourth phase of Marvel
in that it is a lot of redemption of mourning
a lot of of grief and assessing mourning and
I think Sherry does an incredible job staying on
the right side of that line you have to waver like
heroes are gonna make mistakes and she almost does
she almost kills Neymar I think the way she comes
around and the way her connection to her mother
and the way the Queen Mother speaks to her that
that's that's her you know good and evil right
like killmonger and Queen Mother like there's
some really beautiful elements of The Duality
of being a hero through shuri I think she kind
of embodies the whole phase four Arc and I think
shuri uh in her two appearances that we've really
gotten her with has been a standout and sure he
is my number 20 of the heroes in the MCU number 19
we're into the top 20. we're doing it y'all this
is a character I mentioned before as a very very
positive thing I was talking about Kate Bishop
being a fish out of water in that she doesn't
identify fly with being rich while Rich and she's
an underdog in her own way of feeling like a fish
out of water around that world this is a character
that is us and if she wasn't played masterfully
would have been just ridiculed I have said before
and I will say again Community is a show written
by nerds for nerds about nerds Big Bang Theory
is a show written about nerds not by nerds that
feels like it's punching down at nerds I I have
a lot to say about the Big Bang Theory I if you
guys want the only time I don't do negativity you
guys know me I'll do a full video on why the Big
Bang Theory hurt nerd culture for like a decade
but this character could have been the Big Bang
Theory the MCU is what I'm saying she could have
been oh look you cute people with your Avengers
con Miss Marvel shouldn't work this well in the
comic books Miss Marvel is an incredible eye line
into a culture that I'm not as familiar with as
most cultures and through the Miss Marvel comic
book I learned so much about Muslim culture in
a way that is why I love comic books in a very
non-judgmental way in a just a look how much this
works for us look how happy we are look at these
things we do in our lives in this culture all
rituals are crazy if you look at them but we we
often other cultures I love that Miss Marvel
the show leaned as heavily into that as the
comic does while also leaning as heavily into the
family aspect I've said time and time again Miss
Marvel is the Silver age Spider-Man of our day and
I'm on vilani not only had to be the Silver age
Spider-Man of our day but she also had to be all
of us luckily they cast someone that is literally
all of us one of the biggest Marvel Geeks in the
world just happens to be in it now mon villani
Miss Marvel is not only a hero in the MCU she's a
hero in our world she's a delight she's a Gateway
between us and this magical fictional world and uh
everything she does in that show is Pitch Perfect
for the character and for growing out the world
uh the New Jersey elements the things she says to
save people both emotionally and physically the
way she's revealed to be the first mutant very
much opening up the world of like stop judging
other people Heroes don't judge other people and
she's the physical embodiment of that and she's
mom baloney so she's great all right number 18.
talked about movie star elements a few times in
this list and some people just have a nest some
people have a movie star quality this actor came
out on stage they announced phase four and I was
like that's a movie star I don't know who that guy
is but that is just charm on stage as a human and
that man was simul Liu and then two years later
we got Chung Chief and I was right this movie is
one of the best origin comic movies period and
it came out in phase four that is hard to do we
are deep into the MCU it is hard to do the origin
thing now and that's why we've kind of skipped it
a lot of the time sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't when we skip over it this felt like
it was the MCU is already in progress and we still
got that great origin story Heroes do what's right
even if it hurts them Heroes sacrifice this is a
man literally fighting his father this is a man
going up against everything this is an entirely
New World by the time we get to the end of this
film this is so many great comic book archetypes
used correctly and it improves on the comic the
comic book it was written in the 70s and it had
a lot of martial arts tropes and a lot of things
that are very simplistically toned down this
added a lot of depth and layers to it without
Shang Chi as a focal point without the character
of Shang Chi being so interesting and so Charming
again like he's he's funny he's quippy he's
interesting he's got a lot of us in him he's
also effortlessly cool in a way that lends itself
to being a superhero in that origin since I don't
know there's just something about Chung Chi that
is so captivating and I really think that without
simu playing him or without the really really
Pitch Perfect writing and the way they navigated
this expanding of World it wouldn't have worked
and it's all about being a new hero I like that
the whole thing was him getting you know his his
sea legs on him he's figuring his world out it's
a great new addition and I think she's gonna be
one of the biggest Avengers going forward for
good reason and number 17 is Ant-Man now 17 is
a tricky spot to put this character because he's
an OG Avenger but this character is not the OG
Avenger Hank pin this is the side Ant-Man in Scott
Lang and I like that they went this way I think
Hank pen would have been too similar to other
characters it would have been too linear I like
that they chose the guy that is an Avenger that's
an underdog and and Scott Lang's never really
an Avenger but in this case in the MCU the guy's
a thief for good he's Aladdin effectively he's
stealing for good and I love that take on like
heroism has so many different faces it's not cut
and dry this man will do anything for his family
he'll do anything for his daughter and I think
that's gonna come into play in Ant-Man 3 in a
big way and the heroism of him isn't coming from
a place of like pure altruism all the time and
I like that that's so much more nuanced he's just
trying to get by he's just trying to do the right
thing he's fallen in with an interesting crowd I
don't know I like I like that Ant-Man isn't the
cut and dry hero he could have been and I like
that they're leaning into the Ridiculousness
of Ant-Man and it's a genius move to cast the
impossibly affable Paul Rudd everything about
this works for the Scott Lang choice and I think
that's the right choice for the MCU especially
veering from the comic books coming in at number
16 is a man who once was a hero and then was a
villain then he came back around through a lot of
therapy and that's important to do Winter Soldier
the white wolf Bucky Barnes Sebastian Stan he's
got many names I love this taking the character
so much because it was one of the first like oh
my God they're adapting that comic so quickly
Ed Brubaker wrote this winter soldier's story
like a few years before they adapted it Bucky
Barnes was like Uncle Ben he's one of the only
characters that stayed dead and I didn't think
he would work as a guy that came back I thought
one of the great strengths of Steve Rogers was
that loss of his Robin so to speak what man did
they make that Nightwing cool when he came back
I really think they did a great job in casting
Sebastian Stan because you trust him when you
know you shouldn't there's something about him in
Civil War where even when he's you know doing the
right thing you're like man and that guy's a few
code words away from being a problem and there's
always that ticking Time Bomb element and that's
what keeps them interesting as a character uh you
completely know that Bucky Barnes now wants to do
the right thing but there's this undercurrent of
what if what if what if what if what if which is
fascinating I think that's what he's gonna play
in Thunderbolts the what if element what what's
that other side of Bucky and and you know when
he's Winter Soldier he's not on this list this
is the good Bucky Barnes that makes this list and
what makes him unique is that anti-hero element
where he's one decision away from being like we
shouldn't have trusted him and you but you know
you want to he's so good and he's always trying to
do the right thing he's always trying to he's with
Steve to the end of the line he's buying his plums
trying to get his brain to work better uh he's
going to therapy he's a good guy he's a hero love
me some Bucky Barnes one of my favorite characters
all right my lucky number and I talked about it
before a character I didn't think would work on
screen and I'm so glad I was wrong as voiced by
Bradley Cooper which still feels wrong I like
I can't even when I watch the videos of Bradley
Cooper voicing Rocket Raccoon I still think it's
a dub like someone dubbing Bradley group it's just
so good uh Rocket Raccoon is the saddest creature
in the universe according to James Gunn and that
is going to be so heartbreaking I think in May
I think it's going to break us in a whole new
way we all love this not raccoon we all love this
man uh this this creature this this manifestation
of all of our angst and all of our wants like he
he does so he's Mischief incarnate man he's the
Bart Simpson of the the old school part Simpson
of the MCU he is he's always stealing stuff and
he's always like you know he's he's selfish
to a fault but only up to a point I love the
moments where he breaks and you realize that he
cares more about family than himself but he'll
never tell you that he'll never agree to it his
conversation with Thor in Infinity war is one
of my favorite scenes of either Thor or rocket
but it's because of our relationship with rocket
that scene Works he is the best I don't know I
love this character so much he he's an ultimate
hero because he can leave at any point he can
build something to get you know get out of here
he could have left forever ago he was doing it
for the money we meet him teaming up with Groot
to kidnap Star-Lord for money but he's always
wanted family and that's what makes life worth
living is that that connection and we see that
in every decision he makes Love Rocket Raccoon
number 15. all right number 14 is another of the
original og6 the only one that didn't get a movie
for a while now Blackboard didn't get movie for a
while poor these two poor characters Hawkeye y'all
Hawkeye finally got a show and we got to see the
glory that is Jeremy renner's take on Hawkeye I
use every man a lot it is the thing I like about
heroes I like characters that feel like you can
run into them on the street and then they'll do
something otherworldly I like extraordinary but
you need the ordinary as an option Hawkeye is that
to a t this man can do all sorts of extraordinary
things but he's a guy shooting arrows and you
know he acknowledges that I love the awareness
of this character the scene where he recruits or
convinces Wanda to be an Avenger is one of the
great dialogues of the MCU the scene in Age of
Ultron between Hawkeyes family and the Avengers
is my favorite scene in that movie and one of my
favorite scenes in phase two and Age of Ultron
is one of my least favorite films in phase two it
is a is a high highlight of the humanity of being
a hero he's doing this at cost the cost of not
seeing his family the cost of maybe never coming
home to his family he's aware that every day and
he's doing it alongside Gods who are going to be
much more likely to come home than him that's a
hero knowing your sacrifice and still putting that
vest on and shooting your arrows at aliens that's
a hero gym Runner is the every man that needed to
play this character I think he's one of the slept
on cast decisions like when we talk about great
castings in the MCU we don't talk about Jeremy
Runners Hawkeye enough we would not have a good
Hawkeye without this personification he can
very easily go wrong great uniting of character
and actor as well as utilizing this character in
this world in the original Avengers if you don't
have the human element that movie does not work
nearly as well and it's it's smart they've kept
him around number 13 okay so I feel like this
character is gonna be a lot higher on other
people's lists or a lot lower but I feel like 13
is now where people would put this character I
really struggled with where I put this guy because
I like his movies but don't love them I like this
Trail but I love it more than the comic books
often he he doesn't always settle well with me and
that's what's interesting but I still have to put
him high Doctor Strange y'all Dr Strange is the
master of the Mythic arts in the comic books he
has been close to that in the movies what's tricky
has been in a Cumberbatch plays him exquisitely
but I like him better in the team movies than
his solo movies but for the opposite reason of the
Hulk with the Hulk I feel like he's got a little
bit of of handcuffs to what storytelling you can
have because he's stuck in the team movies whereas
Doctor Strange feels like he's emboldened when
he has the versatility of playing with a team I
hope that makes sense what I like about him as an
Avenger is his his sense of humor and his tenacity
and temerity all work on bouncing off of others
but I don't necessarily find it as captivating in
Solo Endeavors and so that's why he's like in this
strange spot where I'm like man I almost want him
in the top 10 but I also want to like 20. so 13
is Doctor Strange it's more of a personal conflict
with the character than maybe anything he's done
obviously he's sacrificed so much uh he has spent
eternities battling he's come to bargain he has
lost his love over and over again through the
Multiverse and was willing to because that's what
Heroes do he's done all the things that make you
a hero I I just want to see him I think much
like Hulk there's just one piece missing that
I'm really excited to see get filled all right top
12 you lovelies we are into the top 12. let's talk
about Thor Thor has been on a walkabout from the
jump Thor's been trying to figure out who he is
what he wants where he belongs and I love that
in a heroic character I am on record since end
game of my great love of the crosshairs of the
big three The Big Three being Captain America
Iron Man and Thor and they they position them
very clearly especially an end game as that big
three in the comics they're the big three of The
Avengers you got cap going from a more selfless
character to making a selfish decision and Iron
Man going from a more selfish character making a
selfless decision and through the middle is Iron
Man and through the middle is Thor figuring out
who he is he is always seeking knowledge he is
always seeking what his Destiny is he's always
losing losing family members he's losing friends
he's losing a sense of identity like the man
is lost as a character that would make a lot of
people eventual that would make a lot of people
depressed and it does he's depressed he's vengeful
certainly but it never puts him out he's never out
of the game he's never on the sidelines he gets
back in there he will always fight for whoever's
left the scenes I again bring up rocket and Thor
the scenes with these two outcasts that have lost
everything or talking that's Thor man that's
the tone that's the man and uh I do consider
his they're the rockiest for me but I think that's
part of it is like this is a man always searching
I feel like the movies are searching too but
just like the character they keep finding new
ways to make this character and he's higher than
my other missing a piece characters because I
feel like it's part of his identity I feel like
Hulk and Doctor Strange are missing something
Thor missing something is part of what drives him
and I think it's really beautiful to make a god
be seeking Humanity as his narrative and I think
that's what Heroes do uh so I love me some Thor he
is number 12. all right number eleven I'm gonna
call her a hero and I'm gonna say she is a hero
and we're gonna you know acknowledge that she's
also on the villain list just like another one of
my top 10 coming up this is a character that is
both a hero and a villain just like they are in
the comic books but when she's a hero she has no
right to be and that's what makes her even better
a hero this is Wanda maximoff this is a miracle
child who was trapped you remembered uh trap you
remember torture uh she is is kidnapped by Hydra
we meet her in a Cell alongside her brother being
manipulated with her powers this is a character
that has gone through the ringer and yet she still
helps people she's lost everything and she still
helps people she she had the incident where she
kidnapped an entire town and she's so good at her
core that we still felt for we still understood
where she was coming from we still wanted to
help in some weird way we still felt bad when
she was like apologizing I don't know there's just
something so good about Wanda and Liz Olson brings
so much Humanity to this this Scarlet Witch of
a character she's a witch but she's seeking how
to be a good person I don't know they're magic
there's magic in this character she has every
right to be evil and that's part of my issue with
Multiverse Madness we've talked about that a lot
she has every right to be evil and she chooses
good and she does it while fighting some of her
own instincts in some of her own history and some
of her own you know her powers are manipulating
others and she doesn't choose to do that often
she's good she's a hero she's she's Wanda a little
wanna Maxwell number 11. all right we're into the
top 10 and this is a Fitting Place for my second
most controversial pick maybe of this whole list
and it's another Spider-Man we had number 50 be
controversial now we're talking number 10. Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man is my number 10 and he is now
part of the MCU thanks to Spider-Man no way home
and he is very high up because I think he is the
most accurate representation of Spider-Man
from the comics now that's only a a part of
this four situation of my my parameters here
for what makes a hero he owns his faults in a
way that most Heroes don't he talks about being
angry and swinging and hitting too hard and not
being able to let that go his journey is constant
reflection he's also amazing and doesn't see it
he's self-effacing he's very to a fault uh overly
humble he he kind of you know self-flagulates like
the man doesn't realize how great he is and
that that's also heroic in its own but it's
also Spider-Man whatever the opposite of boastful
is is truly what Spider-Man is when he's in the
costume he puts on the mask and he's boastful as
a defense mechanisms to stay calm while he's doing
crazy stuff as soon as he's Peter Parker he's
very openly no not this guy demoralizing and I
love that Andrew Garfield is able to capture that
while being so Charming Andrew Garfield I there
was this weird thing where Andrew Garfield was
cast and people were like he's too handsome he's
not nerdy enough you can to be nerdy and have good
genes and also like Pier Parker was never like
that weird schlubby boy like it was a very weird
thing where like handsome doesn't equal cool and
skateboarding doesn't equal cool there was decades
where skateboarding wasn't I don't know I have a
whole problem with the The Amazing Spider-Man
uh era of of judgment on Andrew Garfield and I
think that rubbed off into the present so when
you look at the actual Arc of the character his
journey is about getting knocked down and getting
back up Spider-Man's very much Rocky right like
you got Spider-Man a lot of the iconic images are
Spider-Man under Amazing Spider-Man 2 33 the cover
him under all that rubble and and not stopping
and pushing them through which they used with
Tom Holland very literally but that's Spider-Man
he never he never lets it get too much losing Gwen
Stacy losing you know Captain Stacy losing Uncle
Ben losing Aunt May losing he loses everyone but
he always knows if he can save one more person
it's always about saving one more person I feel
like Andrew Garfield is the Spider-Man that's
always wanting to save one more person to me that
comic book version of the character there is one
Spider-Man left he's in the top 10 as well but I
mean I'm a spidey guy so the two Spiderman but I
I do feel like Andrew Garfield Spider-Man doesn't
get enough love and I do feel like he's gotten
these three amazing portrayals and he deserves
me in the top 10 because he is that Superhero
Arc to a t we see the character grow from one
to three and we see what it means to be a hero
the moment he catches MJ and it completes that
full Arc that full Journey God hero [__] it's
great coming in at number nine is the anti-hero
of the MCU the villain of the Avengers that has
become a hero and this much like Doctor Strange
is a hard one to place because he is certainly
a hero but where do you put Loki like at the
end of the day you love that you don't know to
trust him but through Tom hiddleston's portrayal
through the show especially you know he's gonna
do the right thing and I love that half the time
we've had him on screen I think literally half
the appearances he's done the backstabbing he's
done the wrong thing but the latter half he's
done done the right thing like Avengers Thor
dark World bad guy end of Dark World sacrifice
comes back duplicitous in Ragnarok at the end
of Ragnarok fully good seemingly love and thunder
not present Infinity War good time displaced end
game not present Loki show all good it's literally
like half and half I think but you want to believe
in him to me there's something inherently heroic
in the character they've actually reframed the
character in the comics he's no longer the god of
lies he's the god of stories now I do believe and
I'm not a mythology major I think God of stories
God of lies are are more synonymous in the the old
school mythology again I don't know I don't know
Norse mythology as well as I know comic books but
in the comics they've reframed him as the god
of stories he's such a good hero Tom Hiddleston
portrays him so beautifully in such a positive way
that we want to believe in him they've Rewritten
the comic books that's a hero that's awesome
that's exciting it's retroactively changing the
character Tom hiddleston's so captivating we
want to love him so much I don't know there's
just something inherently altruistic about
even being mischievous through the guise of
Loki number nine coming in at number eight my
favorite drunkard who finally got the screen
time to tell some of the stories she deserved in
love and thunder a character I want to get her
own movie or own TV series a scene stealer and a
half Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie I love every scene
Valkyries in I don't love Thor love and thunder
as much as I I initially did at first viewing I
don't love Ragnarok as much as many others these
aren't my Peak MCU films like the Thor movies
just haven't sung for me that much but this is my
number eight pick and it's another Thor character
Valkyrie there's something about her this is a
character who lost everything in front of her eyes
she lost the love of her life right in front of
her and they cut the scene which felt extra dark
and ironic in hindsight you're like I've lost
everything even the scene validating my loss of
everything and they finally gave her that in love
and thunder I loved the rare screen time where we
got to talk with Valkyrie where we got to digest
what she'd been through and how much she was still
willing to do and not only is she willing to be
a hero on the battlefield she's willing to do the
day-to-day mundane stuff and that isn't talked
about enough sometimes being a hero is dealing
with being a mayor like she's literally running
new Asgard she's doing the day-to-day civilian
level stuff and fighting the big fight she's a
day-to-day hero and a big hero she's a public
figure of Asgard she's doing sponsorship deals as
a goddess she's enduring all this I don't know the
the scenes where she's that beautiful side of
the van art that was Ragnarok with her fighting
those displays that heroism being the last of
her of her people like being the last Valkyrie
I don't know there's there's something about this
character that I really that really speaks to me
and I really want to see more of Tessa Thompson
Valkyrie is my top 10 she's my number eight all
right coming in at number seven is Vision I
actually had Vision at one point at number
three vision is a great character to me because
not only is he worthy he wields mjolnir deftly
and easily not only is he a character that could
be one note he's a synthazoid he is an offspring
he's he's the idea something uh but he is the
anti-ultron in a positive way that is both literal
and metaphorical right so Ultron is uh Humanity
gone awry it's seeing the internet and seeing all
the trauma we've caused and going like nope get
rid of humanity the only way to save the world
vision is the opposite he's the polar to that he's
we always need to believe in others we always need
to have hope even when things go horribly wrong
white vision is literally like a physical a visual
manifestation that I love this character that
you have the opposite of Ultron and they they
spin out of Iron Man right like when you when Iron
Man and Thor have a baby it's this this character
and between the ship of Theseus conversation and
between what he went through in one Division and
his is having to see want to go through all that
and having to suffer and still trying to stay the
The Rock he needed to be try to stay centered
try to try to be there for her no matter what
but also trying to be a hero seeing the horrible
things she was doing there's just so much depth
in this character and Paul Bettany brings so
much heart to this synthazoid I want a vision
show very bad there's rumors that we're getting
one I think this is one of the most interesting
like we could dissect this character for days
choices decisions those are the same thing koi
but you know what I'm saying like what the way he
sees the world is so fascinating uh I love me some
Vision one of my favorite heroes in the MCU and I
don't feel like he's talked about enough I don't
see a lot of lists putting Vision at number seven
but that's where I believe he belongs Vision all
right we're into my top six and fittingly my six
is one of the OG six Avengers we got black widow
now obviously sacrifice has been discussed quite
a bit in this she dives off that Cliffside saving
so many people countless people's Full Sacrifice
very obvious act maybe the most obvious sacrifice
her fighting Hawkeye puts Hawkeye very high on
my list but what keeps Black Widow this high is
every movie there's so many moments where Scarlett
Johansson does little things that make her to me
so much more interesting than sometimes she's
written in the comic books she wields sexuality
as a positive I think sex positivity is really
important and something we don't really talk
about a lot I think it's really interesting that
like it's weaponized here but it never demeans her
I don't love the some of the story lines they
introduced with her they use that as a way to
empower not demean sometimes sexuality in comics
is demeaning straight up but in in this Scarlett
Johansson was able to make it empowering most
the time uh not all the time I'm not nobody's
perfect like like the the writers and directors
and like there are definitely shots and elements
and everything else but with Scarlett Johansson
brought was an empowerment through sexuality which
I think is incredible and I also think that she's
never dumb and like I love when she plays naive
but not dumb and I love the relationship between
her and Steve like them in the car and when her
soldiers said just left on seeing a dialogue and
her movie like what she does for all those women
the the freeing of all those women she was the
only girl in the original Avengers and like you
know we're working towards equality we're working
towards an amount of female Heroes that is pissing
off a lot of people because they're like oh my God
MCU she did this when it was her against the world
it was it was five white dudes and her and I'm
just I'm gonna get plenty of crap from this I'm
sure the [__] Todds and in cells and what was
that group and She-Hulk called her already in the
comments but there's something really empowering
about being a woman just on your own in a team and
and she did that for so many movies and then she
got her own movie after she died and it was still
a dope movie I like the black widow movie there's
something really strong about Black Widow and it's
a human around Gods much like Hawkeye was but
she's a human around gods that has red on her
Ledger that she's public about she owns it it's
it's on the front she completely I've done wrong
let's go forward I'm gonna deal with that that's
my conscience and there's something so heroic
about that love black widow Great Character great
portrayal all right number five this is gonna be a
little brief uh as compared to the other top five
but uh it's because I've talked about this dude
quite a bit if you've seen my Noah home reviews
Etc Spider-Man Tom Holland Spider-Man's my number
five Tom Holland ending his beautiful origin Arc
with six movies Tom Holland becoming Spider-Man
at the end of no way home Tom Holland embodying
with great power comes great responsibility Tom
Holland going through the loss of everything that
makes him Spider-Man and doing it as a hero and
mourning and the shot of him in front of Jonah and
him shouldering everyone being against him and it
not making him a villain him losing so much and
it not turning him and still being so wholesome
and true and but but going earning those emotions
Tom Holland Spider-Man has dealt with the vulture
uh that betrayal he's dealt with so many father
figures lost right you've got the vulture as a
kind of father figure like a stepfather figure
the girl he loves or likes it's high school
so you feel like love but going through that
and those amazing scenes uh a big brother in
Jake Gyllenhaal that that loss of trying to find
someone Tony Stark another father figure lost than
losing out May he's lost all sense of family so
he finds his own family in Ned and MJ and then he
has to let them go he has to lose them by choice
to save everyone and it still doesn't make them
cynical it still doesn't make him a bad for lack
of a better term he still wants to help people and
what does he do he suits up he loses everything he
loses the tech he loses all the things that made
it hard to identify with him as the Spider-Man
the street Spider-Man and he makes a suit after
his brothers he makes a suit that's the blend of
Toby's and Andrews which is one of the great like
oh my God the universe led to this beautiful suit
and like what are the chances that all the legal
would line up and all the story lines would line
up and all the Multiverse of the lineup we'd get
this perfect suit that is a blend of these things
but it's because these are his brothers now he's
found his new family he's found his brothers
and he wears it on his chest literally he wears
his family on his chest and that's Spider-Man and
there's something so special about this character
and this take I I love him he's a hero man he's
Spider-Man number five coming in number four and
yes he is a part of the MCU now and this might
seem like cheating people might be mad and if
you you feel mad just subtract the number from all
the rest and discount this one but I'm putting him
in here because this is a character that is one of
my favorite Comic characters and I think he's even
better in the MCU and that is hard to do that is
Daredevil Daredevil I my god do I love Daredevil
Daredevil is a character that is racked with guilt
that is always pushed to the Limit he uses what
other people perceive as a handicap as a strength
which is something I think is so important like I
talked about with Athena this is a character who
is everything you want a real hero to be like he's
real he does feel Vengeance he does want to hurt
people he does go through mistakes and and trials
and tribulations I love how it really is and then
you get the shield portrayal Daredevil is horny
in all senses of the word pun very much intended
and I love that they're not shying away from that
it's been a very not not a lot of Bonin in the MCU
they bring in Matt Murdock who's got his share of
uh notches on the bedpost and I just love that
they they again sex positivity is so important
so not only are we getting this incredible
character that is nuanced and hilarious and and
incredibly versatile to use as a fighter as an
intellectual as all these things Matt Murdock and
shulk is exceptional Daredevil and She-Hulk
is exceptional and you're not shortchanging
our experience at Charlie Cox is the character of
Netflix we don't know what they're gonna do macro
we don't know what born again is going to mean as
far as continuity and those things but right now
our experience of the character there's no way
those three seasons of the show are not part of
our minds so I'm including it for my head Canon
and that's why some people might discount this
even if I'm only including that Shield show he'd
be in the top 20 but I'm including that so he's
number four everything I want in Matt Murdock is
on screen everything I want in Daredevil is on
screen and arguably some of it's better than some
of the Daredevil Comics I've read and Daredevil is
one of the best written characters ever the Bendis
run the Wade run the the current zadarski around
the Miller run he's always exceptional and he's
still exceptional on screen Charlie Cox brings
one of the best performances period to TV and now
in She-Hulk it doesn't alienate that performance
it only broadens it that is so hard to do to add
after three years of this dark version to add a
levity that's still feels authentic to add so I
just I love it also even in the fighting even in
the fighting like the way the fighting styles like
he's making sure no one gets too hurt but he's
still a little bit more brutal the way he's um you
know trying to make sure everyone's actually in
the wrong he's using his law mind while fighting
is Daredevil the man is always on he's a hero
because he's always aware literally of everyone in
the room and he does what he has to but he doesn't
doesn't take you know shortcuts I love what
Daredevil does as a hero and he puts people down a
lot harder than other Heroes and I think sometimes
that's what's necessary while still being
inherently good all right number three we're into
the top three now the big three I talked about
earlier The Avengers were cap Iron Man and Thor
spoiler alert two of those three guys are left but
one of them it's such an important character that
was introduced in another movie and that's always
hard to do to not get your own movie so when his
own movie was as exceptional and his introduction
was exceptional and every bit of this character
rang true to the actor and the portrayal I gotta
give some love to black panther number three
is Black Panther black panthers introduced in
Civil War and he's immediately so much we lose to
Chaka very quickly we see t'challa morning and he
doesn't kill Baron Zemo so immediately Hiro he's
immediately fighting against all his instincts
doing all those things we we see these fights with
Winter Soldier like some some Chase elements that
chase is so slept on where they literally fight
with a motorcycle and we see the power of Black
Panther and realize that he's always holding back
and what it means to be a hero that's both uh you
know a public figure and a hero and a leader like
this is not only an Avenger not only King he's all
these things at once the amount of responsibility
in her shoulders and then to look at what Chadwick
Boseman had to do while privately fighting cancer
the responsibility in his shoulders play this
character when days on set are not short and it
is not not physical it is most the time it's a
long hard day if your body's fighting itself that
is I can't even imagine so I can't separate what
Chadwick was fighting while this character work
was so incredible then a black man Panther you
know to go even further we we have this incredible
nuanced story of like what it means to be good and
this is a hero who listens to his villain
killmonger had some points the end of black
panther is is t'challa being such a good leader
that he listened to killmonger and embodied a lot
of what he had to say he did open up a lot of the
technology of the world he did start sharing he
did open his doors he didn't do it as a conqueror
because he's not a bad guy but he did it as an
ambassador he wanted the world to be better for
wakanda even at Cost sometimes such a hero such
a leader both in the actor and the portrayal black
panther is somehow Batman and James Bond and you
know a Marvel hero and he's all those things and
number three for a reason Black Panther's such an
incredible hero such an incredible character such
an incredible portrayal and another one that to me
uh is is elevated from a lot of the comics because
I do feel like what we got captured so much of
the spirit in such a quick amount of time like you
can read Decades of Black Panther and you can also
watch these movies and you feel that Beating Heart
of the character and that's so hard to capture
rest in peace to the great Chadwick Boseman and
holy crap what a portrayal of black panther every
time you showed up on screen even in what if
um Star-Lord as uh t'challa that's a hero like
to the the way that someone else embodying that
character and and that versatility of character
like there's just so much in this this role top
two you lovelies number two you gotta you know you
know what's left but which one's it gonna be which
which side am I okay so a lot of people think of
me as a Captain America type and I definitely
love Captain America and a lot of people see
that as mean it's always funny what people see is
you versus how you see yourself my number two I
think is how people perceive me and how I present
myself maybe but I always feel like the number one
my number two is Captain America Captain America
is such a hard character because he's such a Boy
Scout it's so easy to get this wrong I think the
reason is why it's so hard to write Superman is
why it's so hard to write Captain America he is
so much more than the Spangles and he is such a
fixture of Pop Culture he's literally the
flag and it's so easy to mix up patriotism
and and goodness and that's why U.S agent's such
a special character blind patriotism is dangerous
and I think it's really interesting how they they
navigated that especially with Winter Soldier the
second movie of this guy's series they just rip
it all down and they show like hey don't blindly
listen to others these giant government entities
are not necessarily your friends uh institutions
can harm you blindly believing in institutions
can be very dangerous that's one of the lessons as
you get older you realize like you can't blindly
trust these things as your kid you're like that's
safe that's good it's not and Captain America
represents that to me now because the movies
I didn't always get that from the comic book
sometimes I did certainly this is probably the
character that is most improved from the comics
to me the the highest elevation uh because I don't
read a lot of cap Comics I do now but I didn't
he is such a pure character without being boring
or not true he's authentic and pure and that's
hard I believe in his decisions I believe in
what Captain America stands for and I believe in
LA looking at how to take care of your countrymen
without blindly listening to your country uh and I
don't know there's there's something like you you
follow a man like Steve Rogers you follow a man
like Chris Evans and what's great is is you look
at the ark and I and I described it earlier I say
selfless to more selfish I think that's important
yeah I think after a time you need to choose
yourself and and you know as we get older there's
only so much time and you know cap is is literally
a hundred right so even if you're ageless and your
body age is slower you've still been fighting that
fight even if you're Frozen I get it there's time
but he's still been fighting a very long time so
there's something important about that lesson of
like sometimes you have to choose yourself and
I'm not saying selfish is a bad thing I'm saying
choosing yourself he chose Bucky he got to have
his dance and he deserved it he fought long enough
he he you know he served his tours and now he's
time to not be a soldier and I think that's really
important for him to do as a character and I think
that's why he's my number two is it's important
for the character to have that Arc and I think
they landed it and I would love to not see Steve
Rogers come back I know a lot of people want old
man Rogers I know a lot of people want to see some
takes I think a perfect Arc is rare it would be
a sacrifice to see him back maybe Secret Wars as
an alternate but there's still no version of our
head that's going to see Chris Evans be like no no
that's another one bring him back his Human Torch
or not at all it's a beautiful Perfect Dark it's a
well-deserved retirement for a perfect character
and it's a character that I think is even better
than the comics love love Captain America number
two let's do number one there's one character left
you know it's gonna be but let's talk about it
my number one hero in the MCU is Iron Man it's
interesting this is who I identify with when I
watch these movies I totally can see making a lot
of decisions he make I'm impulsive I I want to put
a shield around my world I love that this is a he
he's so drastic that the Ultron thing comes from
him I think making mistakes is also part of being
a hero uh I love that he wants to put a shield
around the world in Ultron and then he ends up
putting a shield around his world in rescue and
his daughter and Tom uh Peter Parker he literally
builds a shield around his world war machine uh
Rhodes all of his people are encased in armor he
does what he can to do his Mission he sacrifices
himself the ultimate heroic move he gives up his
life and this is a character we started with as a
warmonger this is a man profiting off War this is
a man profiting off missiles that sees the harm
in that that grows from that so few people go
that direction I feel like it's so much easier
to get worse as a person than better it's hard
to look up to people that are real because they
are real they will make mistakes it's also hard
to idealize people it's it's good to have yours
it's good to look up to people but not idealize
them because they're still people so many people
that I look up to have made horrible decisions
and I don't look up to them anymore plenty I still
do but there are examples and I think it's really
easy to lose empathy when you get to a certain
point of wealth I think it's easy to forget people
and and that's hard uh and Tony Stark went the
other way uh the more he grew the more he opened
his heart uh even when he didn't want to come
back for Steve Rogers you know after he had a
family in that cabin stuff he came back he knew
what was at stake and he still came back he he
lived the dream and knew that he if he went back
in time it might sacrifice everything but he was
still willing to save half the world the ultimate
sacrifice is willing to sacrifice your family even
beyond that he sacrificed himself not to mention
you know the root of the MCU as Iron Man uh the
first three phases anyway Tony Stark Robert Downey
Jr is the way we got here that first movie is
still near perfect still in my top five all these
movies later charm Charisma intelligence altruism
goodness without being boring these things are
very important in a hero to me apparently I have
something in the boredom but I guess I do the
ultimate hero and and a comic character that was
written as a challenge Stan Lee wanted to make an
unlikable character and he did and then Tony Stark
is somehow such an enduring figure I also think
he represents Americana almost as much as Steve
Rogers does if you look at America it's about like
this American exceptionalism it's about shininess
it's about being all you can be and Steve's the
flag but you know the machinations of America's
Iron Man the shiny suit the being bigger and
Larger than Life Steve goes home at the end of the
night Tony goes out to party like America goes out
in parties so I think that America is represented
in these two Heroes and I think that they're two
sides of the same coin and I think that's why the
inverse of that Arc works the selfish to selfless
and I think America should look at Tony Stark
I think that uh there's something really beautiful
in the Arc of that character and I love him very
much and he's who I identify with most and he's
my favorite hero in the MCU number one is Iron
Man we did it 75 Heroes I am so tired this is
the longest I've ever filmed this is literally
a three hour shoot for one video this is gonna
do it for me please please leave a like leave a
comment I did 75 of these uh five were the second
take I'm gonna totally own that usually these are
all one take five or a second take I'm battling
sickness not covid I got an ear infection that
spread to my nose and throat my whole head is
infected I'm suffering but I want to make sure I
did this because I had a really fun time building
this list up so out of sympathy for my dying uh
please be nicer in the comments than you guys
sometimes are normally 90 of people are great
but the 10 that are mad are so angry so angry so
maybe five percent of those people just lighten
up a little I appreciate each and every one of
you even the angry ones please leave a comment
like subscribe hit that notification Bell share
this with your friends who's your top 75 listen
them or top 20 just go go crazy do whatever you
want in the comments I want to read them I love
seeing your opinions if you strongly disagree let
me know strongly agree let me know try to do it
you know with some kindness uh that is gonna do it
if there's anything else you guys want to see me
rank leave it in the comments below I appreciate
all y'all and if I forgot stuff I'm so sorry one
sick too I didn't re-watch any movies before
listing 75 that's 14 years of just me trying
to remember why I love these characters luckily
I love these characters and I love you thank you
for being here reject nation that is gonna do it
uh okay I'm gonna sleep good night bye be well
stay safe happy holidays get some
sleep okay hydrate call your mom
[Music]